l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée de la proposition loi adoptée
par le Sénat renforçant la sécurité des
élus locaux et la protection des MRES la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires les collectivités
local madame la
présidente
Madame la rapporteur cher violette
spilebou mesdames et messieurs les
députés
Yannick
André
Erwan
Dominique
Camille ce sont des prénoms de
M c'est pas du cinéma c'est dans la
vraie vie des représentants du peuple et
des chevill ouvrière de la
République des élus qui ont été
intimidés menacés
agressés même si
manifestement même un peu de silence
pour écouter le motif de cette
proposition de loi serait le moindre des
respects qu'on leur
devrait il me semble juste que dans
cette
assemblée
précisément au lieu des minutes de
silence et des moments pour se lever ce
soit dans notre attitude à tous que nous
puissions rendre justice à ceux qui sont
des piliers de la
République le cinéma il commence
précisément quand on prend à témoin
une assemblée un texte qui consiste à
rendre hommage pour faire parler de soi
et pour pour être inscrit au comp-rendu
du Journal Officiel le cinéma il
consiste précisément à être capable de
profiter de sujet qui devrai nous
rassembler pour essayer d'en faire des
marqueurs pour se différencier le cinéma
il consiste précisément à se plaindre
des causes sans jamais s'interroger sur
les raisons pour lesquelles nous en
sommes arrivriver
là mesdames et messieurs les députés je
veux vous dire à quel point
nous soutenons l'initiative de cette
proposition de loi j'ai été comme un
certain nombre d'entre vous dans une
autre vie élu local je sais comme
beaucoup d'entre vous ce que le
quotidien d'un élu local peut exiger
comme sacrifice notamment
personnel les noms que je viens de citer
ce sont ceux de représentants de la
nation tout comme nous des élus des
acteurs engagés des hommes et des femmes
qui sarivicent souffant beaucoup et qui
attendent juste qu'on soit au
rendez-vous pour les protéger il y a
dans le lot des amis politiques il y a
dans le lot des ennemis politiques mais
des opposants plus exactement des
adversaires mais jamais des gens qui ne
mérite le qualificatif d'ennemis si
chaque agression est individuellement
insupportable la croissance de leur
nombre rend le phénomène absolument
intolérable 2000
265 agressions d'élus en
2022 2600 en 2023 soit une hausse de 15
% le thème du Congrès des mères l'année
dernière qui insistait sur le fait
qu'agresser les élus s'ans prendre aux
collectivités c'était précisément
agresser la République exige de notre
part une fermeté et une réponse qui soit
proportionnelle à l'atteinte à nos
valeurs le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vient renforcer les
sanctions existantes au sein d'un
dispositif que le gouvernement a déjà
renforcé dès 2019 avant même la
démission du maire de saint-brévin-
lespins la loi engagement et proximité
porté à l'époque par Sébastien le Cornu
a inscrit l'obligation de souscrire une
garantie couvrant le conseil juridique
l'assistance psychologique et les coûts
qui en résulte ainsi que la compensation
de ce coût par l'État pour les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants
le garde des sauts Éric Dupont Moretti a
également transmis au parquet des
consignes d'extrême fermeté dès l'année
2020 ce qui n'était pas une pratique
antérieure et d'autres circulaires
depuis 2021 ont appelé à cette réponse
pénale le gouvernement a également
soutenu la loi du 24 janvier 2023 visant
à permettre aux assemblées d'élus aux
différentes associations de se
constituer partie civile pour soutenir
pleinement au pénal une personne
investie d'un mandat électif qui soit
victime d'agression et des mesures
additionnelles ont été annoncées par la
ministre délégée aux collectivités
territoriales Dominique fort dès le mois
de mai 3400 référents atteintes aux élus
dans toutes les brigades de gendarmerie
et dans les commissariats avec un
objectif simple donné aux élus un point
de contact privilégié pour parler
prévenir les menaces les violences
qu'ell soi physique ou en
ligne renforcer le dispositif alarme élu
permettant à ceux qui se sentent menacés
de se manifester auprès de leur
commissariat ou de leur gendarmerie pour
être secouru rid rapidement également
été fait ces annonces ont été
complétées par la première ministre le 7
juillet dernier dans le cadre du plan
national de prévention et de lutte
contre les violences faites aux élus
avec 12 mesures autour de trois axes
mieux protégé mieux accompagné et faire
en sorte que les responsables des
violences soient plus lourdement
sanctionné la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui rejoint un
certain nombre de propositions du plan
national de prévention de lutte contre
les élus je pense évidemment aux
dispositions de l'article 3 sur le
caractère automatique de la protection
fonctionnelle des maires des adjoints
des conseillers départementaux et
régionaux qui en font la demande y
compris en cas de violence de menace ou
d'outrage dès lors que tout cela se
rattache à l'exercice de leur mandat je
pense aux dispositions de l'article 12
qui vise à rendre systématique le fait
que le procureur informe le maire d'un
classement sans suite pour les affaires
lié à des troubles de l'ordre public sur
le territoire de la commune est
résultant d'une plainte ou d'un
signalement qui émane d'un
maire la proposition de loi issue du
Sénat sur lequel nous sommes appelés à
débattre aujourd'hui n'est pas un
commencement mais une continuité je
souhaite saluer le travail transpartisan
sur le sujet
qui avec Violette
spilebou et avec tout le travail fait
par le député Sébastien Jumel sur le
statut de l'élu au sein de la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales a permis
que ce texte soit très largement soutenu
par tous les groupes parlementaires à
l'occasion du travail en commission et
je salue également les présidents des
commissions correspondantes le président
olier et le président
Valence comme je vous le disais au début
de mon propos nous sommes dans
l'ensemble favorable àex avec une
sensibilité particulière mais avec une
espérance c'est que nos débats soient
précisément à la hauteur des enjeux
nombre d'entre vous ici ont déjà été
maires élus départementaux régionaux ou
locaux de chaque côté de ces bans en
dépit de ce qui nous oppose bien souvent
nous connaissons le rôle démocratique et
essentiel que les élus de proximité
jouent la première manière à la fois de
les défendre et de les protéger c'est de
les respecter en prenant le temps de
regarder et de voter des dispositions
qui aent en le sens et de le faire avec
le respect que nous leur
devons je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à madame violette spidbot
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
[Applaudissements]
République madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues
l'année 2024 doit être celle des élus
locaux vous venez de le rappeler la
proposition de loi que dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être rapporteur aujourd'hui
constitue le premier acte de
l'engagement et de la rec naissance de
la représentation nationale envers les
élus locaux le Premier ministre Gabriel
Attal l'a exprimé clairement devant le
Sénat il y a quelques jours nous agirons
main dans la main avec les élus locaux à
l'écoute de leurs préoccupations de
leurs alertes et de leurs attentes élu
local c'est le plus beau des engagements
mais c'est aussi être en première ligne
face à une société qui se brutalise
cette proposition de loi transmise par
le Sénat constitue le volet sécurité
d'un ensemble plus large de mesures
législative ou non qui doivent permettre
une rénovation profonde du statut de nos
élus j'avais également déposé en juillet
dernier après un travail approfondi une
proposition de loi pour renforcer la
lutte contre les violences et je suis
particulièrement heureuse que les
travaux des deux chambres se rejoignent
aujourd'hui sur cet enjeu important nous
venons par ailleurs avec Sébastien Jumel
que je salue de transmettre au bureau de
l'Assemblée une proposition de loi
portant réforme du statut de l'élu local
qui est issue des travaux que nous avons
mené dans dans le cadre d'une mission
transpartisane confiée par la Délégation
aux collectivités territoriales nous
voulons reconnaître et valoriser
l'engagement et créer un véritable choc
d'attractivité je tiens avant tout à
réaffirmer que ce combat nous appartient
à toutes et à tous sur l'ensemble de ces
bancs toutes et tous nous sommes des
élus souvent des élus locaux toutes et
tous nous avons été victimes de violence
à cause de notre engagement toutes et
tous nous avons conscience de la crise
profonde d'évocation qui qui touche
notre pays c'est aux élus locaux que
s'adresse plus particulièrement cette
proposition de loi nous l'avons répoté
en commission l'élu local et le maire en
particulier est apporté d'embrassade
apporté d'engueulade mais il ne doit pas
être apportter de BAFF d'insultes de
diffamation ni lui ni sa famille ne
doivent l'être sinon c'est la démocratie
toute entière qui
recule quelques chiffres suffisent à
murer l'ampleur du phénomène plus de
1300 maires ont présenté leur démission
depuis juin 2020 lors des élections
municipales 2020 106 communes n'avaient
pas de candidats ce blous des maires et
cette perte de l'envie de s'engager
doivent être mis en regard avec une
hausse inédite des violences vous avez
rappelé ce chiffre en 2022 2265 fait
d'atteintte aux élus 32 % de plus que
l'année précédente et cette année en
2023 nous allons attendre 15 % de plus
que 2022 mais les chiffres ne suffisent
pas lorsqu'on parle de violence il faut
aussi des noms et des visages et dans
les 10 minutes qui se me sont imparties
ce soir je ne je ne veux pas le faire
sans égrainer quelques noms qui nous ont
marqué récemment je pense d'abord à
jean-mthieu Michel maire de signe mort
le 5 août 2019 dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions je pense au maire de laell
rose Vincent jambrin et je pense à sa
femme et à ses deux enfants dont le
domicile personnel a fait l'objet d'une
attaque particulièrement choquante je
pense au maire de Saint-Brévin Lespin
Yannick Moret dont le domicile a été
incendié et je pense à sa successeur
Dominique Pacco doreté paracco pardon
également menacé je pense à Olivier
lepque maire de Carnac menacé de mort et
placé sous protection de la
gendarmerie je pense à Anne Françoise
piedalu mère de plourescan dont les
freins de la voiture ont été sectionnés
je pense à Édouard Babel mère de manière
roué de coup je pense à André mniier
maire de venant également tabassé et le
mot n'est pas trop fort je pense enfin à
Bernard Gérard maire de Marc embarel
dans ma circonscription et président de
l'Association des Maires du Nord dont
les câbles de freinage du véhicule
personnel ont été sectionnés je salue à
cette occasion toutes les associations
d'élus qui peuvent désormais se porter
se constituer partie civil et qui le
font très souvent au côté des maires les
chiffres rejoignent les visages que je
viens d'évoquer dans 6 cas sur 10 les
élus concernés par ces agressions sont
des maires élus les plus proches de nos
concitoyens mais les premiers à subir
les attaques contre la République ce
sont eux que nous devons protéger en
priorité
aujourd'hui je salue le travail du Sénat
qui nous permet avec cette proposition
de loi d'avancer sur la question de la
protection des élus locaux et je
remercie François Noël buffet son auteur
et Catherine diolco qui en a été la
rapporteur le texte prévoit trois volets
de mesures importantes le titre premier
renforce les sanctions aggravation des
peines encourues création d'une peine de
travail d'intérêt général en cas
d'injure publique ainsi que d'une
circonstance aggravante lorsque la
victime de harcèlement est titulaire
d'un mandat allongement des délais de
prescription pour les injures publ et
puis aussi une meilleure protection des
candidats en cas d'atteinte à leur vie
privée le titre 2 améliore la prise en
charge des victime de violence l'octroit
automatique de la protection
fonctionnelle pour ceux qui ont des
fonctions exécutives la prise en charge
par la commune des restes à charge pour
les dépassements d'honoraires des élus
victimes de violence et puis la
possibilité d'obtenir une assurance pour
les permanences électorales l'extension
du bénéfice de la protection
fonctionnelle aux candidats est aussi
importante ainsi que l'ouverture du
droit à une prise en charge par l'État
des dépenses engagées pour leur sécurité
durant la période électorale cet article
constitue une grande nouveauté et une
avancée essentielle pour pour encourager
l'engagement dans notre pays et protéger
les candidats qui sont les élus de
demain il me tient particulièrement à
cœur vous le savez et puis le titre 3 il
a pour objectif de renforcer la prise en
compte des réalités des mandats électifs
locaux par les acteurs judiciaires et et
tactiques en renforçant l'information
des maires par les procureurs en
encourageant le dépaysement de certaines
affaires et en renforçant les CLSPD
conseils locaux de de prévention et de
sécurité de prévention de la
délinquence preuve que la lutte contre
les violences faites aux élus locaux est
un partager nous avons en commission des
lois adopté 36 amendements qui viennent
des différents groupes 36 amendements
adoptés sur un texte qui ne comptait que
14 articles ce n'est pas rien et ça
témoigne de notre volonté de travailler
collectivement pour enrichir ce texte
important et dans le respect que vous
appeliez de vos vœux monsieur le
ministre nous avons notamment prévu des
peines aggravées puissent s'appliquer
lorsque les violents sont exercés sur un
ancien élu en raison des décisions
prises dans son mandat passé nous avons
élargi à l'outrage les cas dans lesquels
le juge peut prononcer une peine de tige
étendu le champ de la circonstance
aggravante aux atteintes à la vie privée
des proches des personnes concernées
encourager la signature de conventions
locales entre les associations d'élus
locaux les préfits et les procureurs de
la République préciser les dispositions
qui permettent le remboursement des
dépenses de protection des candidats
menacés et l'extension de la protection
fonctionnelle à ses candidats apporter
des modifications à la composition des
CLSPD etc créer plusieurs articles
additionnels prévoyant la la remise de
différents rapports au Parlement je
voudrais insister pour terminer quelques
instants sur la question de la
protection fonctionnelle monsieur le
ministre car il me semble absolument
indispensable d'en élargir le bénéfice à
l'ensemble des élits locaux pas
seulement ceux qui ont des fonctions
exécutives et d'étendre la protection à
la famille de ses élus et à celle des
candidats ce qui constitue pour nous une
condition sineéquanone à l'exercice
serin d'un mandat contrainte par les
règles de recevabilité financière de
l'article 40 de la Constitution je n'ai
pas pu déposer ces amendements et face
aux difficultés juridiques du
gouvernement pour le déposer de son côté
nous avons intégré des mesures prévoyant
l'élargissement de la protection
fonctionnelle dans la proposition de loi
que nous portons avec Sébastien Jumel
j'espère donc que dans 2 mois dans ce
premier trimestre nous pourrons avoir un
débat et trouver une solution pour y
arriver ensemble pour conclure je
voudrais répondre à un préjugé celui que
nous créerions des dispositifs destinés
à nous protéger nous-mêmes à créer pour
les élus un droit particulier qui en
ferait des privilégiés je tiens à dire
ici que les élus ne sont pas des
privilégiés et qu'ils ne doivent
évidemment pas l'être ils sont
malheureusement trop souvent aujourd'hui
non pas des privilégiés mais des hommes
et des femmes à abattre par des moyens
indignes que sont la violence physique
la violence verbale la rumeur ou
l'atteinte à la vie privée nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter non seulement
parce que ce n'est pas acceptable en soi
mais surtout parce qu'en attaquant des
élus quelle que soit leur fonction on
met à mal la République Sébastien Jumel
avec qui j'ai eu la chance de mener
pendant plusieurs mois des travaux sur
le statut de l'élu le résumer dans une
formule que je me permets de lui
emprunter prendre soin des élus c'est
prendre soin de l'importance de la
démocratie vivante que constitue la
commune pilier d'une République Pr
présente partout et pour tous je vous
remercie et je vais remercier mes
collègues tous mes collègues d'avoir
participer aux auditions et à des débats
en commission d'un très bon niveau et
avec beaucoup de respect mutuel et puis
je vais remercier il paraît que c'est
pas traditionnel mais j'ai le temps nos
deux administratrices marine Manzano et
Dianne boucher qui ont fait un travail
d'approfondissement formidable pour
qu'un certain nombre de nos volontés
politiques communes puissent être
traduite concrètement dans nos
amendements ce qui n'était pas mince à
faire et nous avons aujourd'hui de beaux
débats devant nous je vous
remercie je vous
remercie le premier orateur dans la
discussion générale c'est Monsieur Paul
mollac pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outrem et
[Applaudissements]
territoire votre présidente donc que ne
feraiis-je pour vous faire plaisir
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues donc je je ne sais pas si nos
concitoyens se rendent toujours compte
de ce que font les élus locaux pour eux
et en particulier les maires alors
monsieur le ministre je ne peux pas tous
les nommer parce que 86 maires ça fait
beaucoup
mais quelques anecdotes tout de même un
mère me dit qu'il a retrouvé un de ses
concitoyens nu en train de prier sous la
pluie dehors sur la rue et qu'il voyait
le diable à peu près
partout pas seulement ça arrive ailleurs
tu sais bien
et bon ça c'est une chose une autre
chose c'est le maire c'est celui qu'on
appelle quand il y a des bêtes en
divagation en pleine nuit c'est aussi
celui qui qui va alors le mien me dit
bah tiens j'ai j'ai j'ai pas enc enlever
la trossonneuse que j'avais après la
tempête
kan bref donc ça veut dire que avec les
les les employés communaux en fait il
est allé dégager les routes avec les
quelques arbres un certain nombre quand
même qui bloquaient en fait les routes
et puis on a des choses particulièrement
déplaisantes ceux qui évidemment se font
attaquer ceux qui aussi vont avec la
gendarmerie pour annoncer aux parents
que l'enfant est dans la nuit et et bien
malheureusement a eu un accident et
qu'il n'est plus de ce monde le genre de
chose dont on se passe bien quand même
et donc c'est tout ça que les mères font
c'està dire qu'en fait je dirais ils
font beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils devrai
faire beaucoup plus et c'est pour ça que
quand on voit certains qui sont menacés
quelqu'un parfois d'ailleurs on met le
feu à leur maison on l'a vu à
Saint-Brévin ou qui reçoivent des coups
de fusil et cetera sur leur maison c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable parce
que la plupart des mares que je vois
sont des gens admirables qui ont
vraiment cheviller au corps l'intérêt
général vraiment chevillé au corps alors
après ils sont pas parfaits évidemment
c'est c'est pas cette question là mais
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
le travail qu'ils font il est ils sont
indemnisés relativement peu un certain
nombre de conseillers municipaux
d'ailleurs travaillent gratuitement ils
ont rien du tout et ils le font parce
qu'ils ont un sens de l'intérêt général
et de ce que l'on doit tout simplement à
ses concitoyens quand on en a la
possibilité et qu'on peut le faire voilà
donc il y a pas bien même pas la plupart
du temps une question d'é goût et donc
c'est moi j'ai enfin en tout cas pour
les
côtoyer depuis longtemps et depuis que
je suis député encore plus on a la
chance d'avoir des gens qui sont là pour
la cohésion sociale qui la soutienne et
que s'il n'était pas là franchement je
ne sais pas si ce pays tournerait aussi
bien je pense qu'il tournerait plus mal
et ça me paraît évident et c'est pour ça
que cette proposition de loi elle me
paraît
bienvenue alors le premier point on l'a
dit c'est de renforcer les sanctions bon
je suis pas sûr que ce soit forcément la
chose la plus évidente parce que comme
disait
Badinter le justiciable se balade
rarement avec un un code sous son bras
mais ça permet de montrer l'importance
que l'on accorde aux élus locaux de les
mettre au même niveau que les forces de
l'ordre par exemple c'est un peu ce
qu'on fait dans cette proposition de loi
la deuxième chose c'est la protection
fonctionnelle ça ça me paraît primordial
parce que on voit très bien ce qui va se
passer dans un certain nombre de
communes le maire va
rechigner à mettre ça dans le budget
déjà qu'un certain nombre ne prenne pas
l'indemnité c'est la plus importante à
laquelle ils ont droit donc ils vont
rechigner vont dire ah oui mais bon il y
aura peut-être rien donc je vais pas
prendre d'assurance et cetera en fait
ils sont soucieux la plupart du temps
des des deniers publics et donc si on
veut que ce soit efficace et bien tout
simplement faut que l'État la prenne en
charge je suis content de voir que pour
toutes les communes inférieures à 10000
€ c'est ce que nous allons faire alors
j'aurai un petit amendement parce que
quelquefois dans les savez entre les les
les AE et les crédits de paiement
quelquefois il y a des petites
différences qui font que on ne peut plus
les autorisation d'engagement peuvent
pas être mis en place c'est pour ça que
la MF m'avait donné ce cet amendement
qui me semble important et puis on étend
aussi cette protection aux candidats et
un certain nombre de personnes qui si
vous voulez vont se porter aux élection
je pense que nous faisons uvre utile et
donc je le dis hein notre groupe est
très est favorable à cette proposition
de loi et évidemment la votera vous
remcici la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Thomas rudig du groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais commencer cette
intervention tion en plongeant au cœur
d'une question essentielle pour notre
démocratie notre République la représent
la protection des représentants du
peuple français alors que nous nous
penchons sur cette proposition de loi
visant à renforcer la sécurité des élus
locaux et des maires il est crucial mes
chers collègues de prendre conscience de
l'ampleur des défis auxquels nous
faisons face pour illustrer ce défi
permettez-moi de partager avec vous
quelques réflexions et expérience
personnelle en ma qualité d'élu local
car comme grand nombre d'entre vous je
suis élu local de un certain nombre
d'années j'ai été maire d'arrondissement
à Lyon conseiller général du Rône et
actuellement conseiller métropolitain de
Lyon j'ai malheureusement été victime à
plusieurs fois et témoin de comme
beaucoup d'entre vous de la montée
inquiétante de la violence et de
l'hostilité dirigée contre les élus
locaux des actes aieux et des menaces
obscèes qui portent atteinte à
l'exercice même de nos fonctions
démocratiques des actes qui à l'époque
était dicté par la volonté de me faire
renoncer à mes engagements mes combats
politiques par exemple avec avec la
dégradation de ma permanence de campagne
à Lyon en 2020 par des militants d'un
groupuscule d'extrême droite bien connu
malheureusement génération identitaire
parce que je me battais avec certains
d'entre vous d'ailleurs pour leur
dissolution ce que nous avions à
l'époque obtenu avec Gérald armanin
ou des
menace lors de l'ancienne législature
reçu avec d'autres collègues Parlement
de différents bancs pour nous inciter à
ne pas voter le Pass vaccinal ces
incidents ne sont malheureusement pas
isolés ils témoigne d'une tendance
préoccupante qui met en péril la
stabilité de notre démocratie locale les
récentes tragédies vous l'avez rappel
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre survenu à Saint-Brévin et à l'ï
les rose raisonne encore douloureusement
dans nos esprits rappelant la
vulnérabilité des élus locaux en pensant
à Vincent jean-brin maire de l'a rose
Yannick morz ancien maire de
Saint-Brévin Marie-Hélène toraval maire
de roman surizer André Mondange encore
récemment maire de pH de Roussillon
ainsi qu'à tous ces édiles invisibles
qui subissent quotidiennement ces
violences je ressens un profond respect
pour leur courage et leur détermination
à servir la République malgré tout il
est crucial mes chers collègues de
souligner que ces attaques ne sont pas
simplement le fruit de divergence
politique ou de critique légitime ce
sont des attaques délibérées contre les
fondements même de notre démocratie elle
vise à faire taire la voix de ceux et
celles qui ont été démocratiquement élus
pour représenter les Françaises et les
Français il est alarmant de constater
que la violence à l'encontre des élus
devienne de plus en plus fréquent et
intense ces exemples bien que choquants
ne représentent que la pointe de
l'iceberg d'un phénomène plus vaste et
inquiétant et en tant que législateur il
est de notre devoir de mettre en place
des mesures robustes pour y faire face
est ce que c'est ce que nous allons n
nous y en loyer en soutenant cette
proposition de loi initiée par le Sénat
notamment par le président de la
commission des lois vous l'avez rappelé
madame la rapporteur François Noël
buffet et en votant 36 amendements en
commission des lois pour renforcer
davantage la portée de cette proposition
de loi nous députés réaffirmons notre
engagement dans cette direction nous
devons agir mes chers collègues avec
détermination et fermeté pour garantir
que nos concitoyens puissent exercer
leur responsabilité politique sans
craindre pour leur sécurité
ainsi je vais pas revenir trop sur cela
vous l'avez rappelé madame la rapporteur
sur les différentes dispositions mais
cette proposition de loi va permettre
d'aggraver les peines en cas de violence
fait contre les élus locaux cette
proposition de loi va permettre de de
créer des peines de travaux d'intérêts
généraux en cas d'injure ou d'autrage
comme nous l'avons adopté en commission
des lois contre les élus locaux et
contre les personnes détentrices de
l'autorité publique et cette proposition
de loi va nous permettre d'octroyer de
FA son automatique la protection
fonctionnelle aux exécutifs locaux nous
ne devons pas simplement réagir aux
incidents une fois qu'ils sont se sont
produits mais également prévenir leur
survenu en érigeant une société où la
violence et l'intimidation n'ont pas
leur place et le sens de ce texte qui
témoigne également du travail ancien et
constant mené par le gouvernement je
tiens rappeler le travail fait par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald armenin
et aussi vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre la Ministre chargée des
collectivités territorial Dominique fort
demain ce travail devra se poursuivre
mes chers collègues ici à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense notamment aux
propositions sur le statut de l'élu qui
sont portés notamment par vous madame la
rapporteur spilbout et par notre
collègue Sébastien Jumel mais aussi dans
nos territoires avec tous les acteurs
élus association d'élus policiers et
magistrats le groupe Renaissance votera
cette proposition de loi sécurité des
élus locaux et protection des maires je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
maintenant à Madame edvich di pour le
groupe rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national merci madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur chers collègues
depuis quelques mois en effet nous avons
l'impression qu'une nouvelle étape a été
franchie dans l'explosion de la violence
à l'égard des élus locaux cet effet est
notamment dû au fait que le lundi 3
juillet au moment des émeutes qui ont vu
se multiplier les agressions à
l'encontre des élus ou de leur familles
l'association des mares de France a
appelé un rassemblement républicain
auquel les élus du rassemblement
national ont bien évidemment participé
nous y avons participé pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord par solidarité avec
les victimes ensuite pour alerter le
gouvernement qui reste malheureusement
relativement passif face à ce fléo et
qui s'est donné bonne conscience en
annonçant un petit plan à 5 millions
d'euros enfin par amitié avec nos
collègues élus ou militants du
rassemblement national de trop
nombreuses fois agressés en exerçant
leur mission ou en contribuant à
l'expression démocratique de notre pays
et ce dans l'indifférence générale voire
coupable de l'immense majorité des élus
non RN Perm permettez-moi d'adresser un
soutien amical à Muriel diredzé
conseillère régional grandest au
collaborateurs du Groupe rassemblement
national au conseil régional de PACA à
Albin frécher conseiller régional de
nouvelle aququitaine ou encore à notre
collaborateur pierre lecamuch aux
agressions s'ajoutent de très nombreuses
information qui aurait depuis bien
longtemps dû alerter le gouvernement et
aboutir au vote d'un texte visant en
urgence à protéger les élus leurs
familles les candidats aux élections et
les anciens élus j'en veux pour preuve
le rapport sénatorial de 2019 de
Philippe Bas qui indique que sur les
3812 participants à son enquête 92 % ont
déjà subi des incivilités injures menace
ou agression physique je voudrais aussi
faire référence à l'enquête publiée en
mars 2021 par l'Association des Maires
d'Île-de-France intitulé violence contre
les élus locaux qui estime qu'à la suite
de la promulgation de la loi engagement
et proximité de 2019 qui avait pourtant
annoncé un renforcement de la protection
fonctionnelle des élus seulement 6 % des
élus locaux estiment que cette
protection est suffisante par ailleurs
comment ne pas évoquer les très nombreux
ouvrages publiés par des maires en 2020
qui expriment leur désarrois et leur
sentiments d'abandon au quotidien en
outre les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur sont alarmants en 2023 2300
atteintes aux élus ont été enregistrées
soit une haosse de 15 % par rapport à
2022 et cette situation d'ensuvagement
n'épargne absolument pas les communes
rurales dans mon département Gironde des
élus d'ivrac ou de rionon ont été
victimes d'agression enfin l'association
des maires de France déplore la
démission d'environ 40 mères par mois
soit 10 de plus que lors de la mandature
2014-2020 toujours en Gironde plus d'une
vingtaine d'élections partielles ont
déjà été enregistré depuis le début du
mandat après de multiples démissions
face à cette situation dramatique il est
normal que 2/ers des Français indi qu'il
pourrait renoncer à se présenter à une
élection en raison d'une crainte pour
leur sécurité ou celle de leur famille
tout comme l'on peut comprendre que 5 %
des maires actuels selon laamf
envisagent de ne pas se représenter en
2026 ces chiffres restent
incontestablement risque
incontestablement d'affaiblir encore
davantage notre République qui en 2020
avait vu 106 communes s candidats au
municipal pour comparaison en 2014 il y
en avait 62 enfin 64 % des citoyens
estiment que la sécurité des élus locaux
n'est pas assurée il était donc plus
qu'urgent de se réveiller cette
proposition de loi bien qu'insuffisante
va dans le bon sens en effet elle va
satisfaire les 81 % des Français
favorables au renforcement des sanctions
pénales pour les auteurs de violentes
faesses aux élus et même les 57 % de
sympathisants de la France insoumis qui
se disent favorables aux mesures de
protection des élus mais ils seront
probablement déçu de voir que leurs
parlementaires sont profondément
déconnectés des réalités CAPA de
multiplier les amendements voulant créer
des allègements de sanction fustigeant
une imaginaire surenchère pénale et
alimentant ainsi le laxisme judiciaire
moteur de l'ensauvagement de notre
société mais ces amendements auront au
moins un mérite justifier leur le surnom
qui leur est de plus ou plus plus en
plus souvent accollé ils sont des
députés de la France non pas insoumis
mais incendiaire heureusement les
Français et les élus de notre République
peuvent compter sur Marine Le Pen et les
députés du rassemblement national pour
les défendre et les
protéger ainsi afin que cette loi ne se
limite pas comme c'est le cas à des
mesurettes administrative ou pire à un
anième exercice d'affichage ou de
communication notre groupe souhaite
l'enrichir et proposer d'aller plus loin
malheureusement je dois vous faire part
de mon profond regret suite à la
déclaration d'irrecevabilité réservée à
un certain nombre de nos amendements
toutefois les députés du rassemblement
national défendront de nombreux autres
amendements qui iront par exemple dans
le sens d'une protection fonctionnelle
étendu au collaborateurs d'élus nous
demanderons la publication d'un rapport
détaillé par département de ces
phénomènes de violence pour qu'on arrête
de nous cacher la vérité nous souhaitons
que pour une fois vous ne vous enfirmiez
pas dans le sectarisme qui vous
caractérise et que dans l'intérêt
général vous montriez que vous êtes au
côté des 509000 élus locaux qui font la
richesse et la force de notre démocratie
je vous remercie merci la parole s'il
vous plaît mes chers collègues est à
Monsieur Sébastien R pour le groupe la
France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la la rapporteur
chers collègues ce texte se P de mots
car il ne renforce pas la sécurité des
élus locaux et la protection des mers si
c'était la réelle intention il nous
faudrait alors conduire deux autres
types d'action d'une part empêcher que
les inadmissibles actes violents contre
les élus ne soient commis et d'autre
part s'attaquer aux causes de ces
violences spécifiques au malaise
démocratique or ici nous n'allons ni
retenir la main ni ni les mots des
agresseurs ni agir sur les causes
regardez le
texte au titre 3 nous évoquerons les
réunion du CLSPD dont on rabaisse les
ambitions notamment sur les violences
intrafamiliales et nous nous opposons à
ce recul au titre 2 nous améliorons et
nous y sommes favorables
l'accompagnement des élus victimes le
Titre 1 alourdit les peines pour les
auteurs de violence sur les élus leurs
familles et nous dénonçons ici l'inutile
escalade des peines l'augmentation des
violences contre les élus jette une
lumière cruelle sur l'augmentation de la
défiance envers nos institutions l'année
dernière nous avons eu déjà à voter sur
ce texte sur ce sujet nous recommençons
aujourd'hui demain nous aurons une loi
sur le statut de l'élu aujourd'hui et
demain ne détournons pas les yeux ne
singeons pas comme nous l'avons trop
entendu durant les travaux en commission
une loi du italion malgré le fait que la
franceç est soumise soit
particulièrement visée en ce moment nous
ne céderons pas à laassuren cher nous
suivons l'avis éclairée du Conseil
économique social et environnemental
face à l'augmentation des faits
criminels qui compte des victimes sur
des élus de de tous les bords et surtout
face à la surexploitation médiatique
nous ne devons pas céder à tout ce qui
alimente un populisme
pénal issue de d'une surréaction à des
émotions un fait divers égal une loi et
justifie une surenchè pénale la
recommandation du C est donc d'arrêter
de faire des lois d'affichage et d'agir
sur le sens de la peine c'est pourquoi
nous serons favorables aux peines
d'intérêts généraux mais pas la
surenchère pénale proposé martial fouco
directeur du cvipof explique dans une
enquête auprès de 8000 maires que ces
maires demandent plus de protection mais
sans demander un cadre répressif plus
grand il réclame et nous réclamons aussi
des décisions de justice plus rapides
pour que le climat délé terre ne
s'installe pas durant des mois il n'y a
pas de nouveaux moyens pour la justice
dans ce texte sans décision de justice
rapide un autre phénomène s'installe les
élus n'osent pas porter plainte surtout
dans les petites communes de peur
d'aggraver les conséquences sur eux et
leur familles c'est pourquoi nous avons
déposé des amendements renforçant la
médiation pour rééquilibrer ce texte je
demande donc au gouvernement de les
reprendre en levant le gage j'en appelle
aussi à un peu de cohérence et de ne pas
une semaine après le consensus sur la
loi médiation comme outil de prévention
de conflit de dire qu'en fait ce n'était
que du vent les décisions rapides de
justice protège les élus l'intervention
de médiateur quand la situation se
dégrade aussi mais ici ils ont une vertu
supplémentaire qui semble pour l'instant
hors de réflexion de nombreux députés en
brandissant les circonstances
aggravantes pour alourdir les peines
nous fonctionnarisons les élus locaux et
nous les plaçons à part au-dessus des
citoyens de Primus interparess premier
parmi les pères on dérive lentement vers
un magistère populi un maître du peuple
face à la défiance du peuple envers les
élus il faut plus de démocratie plus de
dialogue plus humain mais sur tout cela
votre texte est muer pour protéger les
élus nous demandons comme Philippe rioot
maire de Grini lui-même agressé un réel
pouvoir d'agir des maires afin de
répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
car c'est bien là la source des mots
lorsque l'état recule nous exposons les
élus qui restent à porté de BAFF
arrêtons de dépouiller les communes de
leur autonomie financière et fiscale
rappelons enfin comme l'écrivait jores
que la condition de l'ordre et le
progrès la justice et la liberté alors
pour protéger nos élus locaux parce que
nous préférons que la République soit
aimée plutôt que crainte banisson
régression sociale injustice et recul
des libertés je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
R la parole est à Monsieur raphaelan
berger pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues ce n'est pas seulement les
agress envers les élus qui augmentent
depuis de nombreuses années c'est bien
de façon générale la défiance et les
agressions de plus en plus physique de
l'ensemble des agents publics qui
devient visible qu'il s'agisse
évidemment des forces de l'ordre des
agents du service public des agents
d'accueil dans nos services publics même
dans nos mairies et de surcroix des élus
qui ont quand même une place bien
particulière dans notre système
politique tout ça nous interroge sur
notre façon de vivre ensemble quelle
société voulons-nous comment
pouvons-nous encore avoir envie de vivre
ensemble lorsque ceux qui s'engagent
pour les autres sont les premier à être
victime des agressions dans cette
société de l'individualisme dans cette
société où chacun veut une réponse
immédiate et de plus en plus rapide à
son problème particulier bien j'ai une
conviction c'est que une partie des
répons qui feront cohésion se trouvent
dans la défense des libertés locales
parce que ce sont ces libertés locales
qui nous permettront de façon plus
générale de réapprendre ce qu'est la
démocratie qui est un apprentissage
permanent et jamais acquis peut-être
est-ce là la défaillance collective que
nous avons eu de considérer que la
démocratie était définitivement acquise
alors cet après-midi ce soir nous
débattrons de ces deux grands deux
grandses idées si abstraites et pourtant
si concrètes dans le quotidien de nos
concitoyens la démocratie et la
République la démocratie qui est cet
engagement que nous avons tous c'est
chacun à défendre nos idées au même
niveau que celles des autres et à
trouver un moyen pacifique de régler nos
conflits et de prendre des décisions et
la République qui est là pour protéger
protéger la le dialogue protéger cet
espace démocratique protéger ce
processus de de décision collective
protéger localement la
délibération tout ça génère une crise
profonde dans l'engagement local et
notamment celui des mirres et ça
s'observe à l'occasion des différentes
élections qui se suivent de moins en
moins de candidats parfois même de plus
en plus de difficultés à trouver des
listes dans certaines communes et les
raisons de cette crise démocratique
locale sont nombreuses les violences et
les agressions des élus on y reviendra
mais je crois qu'il y en a d'autres que
nous ne pouvons pas oublier cet
après-midi dans notre débat d'abord
l'organisation progressive de
l'impuissance de l'action publique
locale l'empilement des normes l'organis
allambiqué d'un certain nombre de
compétences combien de fois chers
collègues Fabrice brin avons-nous
débattu dans cet hémicycle de la
compétence ha et assaainissement qui est
une demande forte des élus locaux à
laquelle le gouvernement reste désormais
sourd depuis 7 ans mais c'est parfois
aussi la volonté d'organiser les
échelons les uns contre les autres je ne
peux pas oublier ce ministre du Budget
qui à l'occasion de la distribution de
feuille
d'imposition envoyait un hashtag sur
Twitter balance ton maire c'était un
ministre dans un gouvernement il y a pas
si longtemps que ça et puis enfin la
question de des libertés locales
budgétairees financière fiscale avec une
complexité de plus en plus importante et
la difficulté pour les élus locaux
d'expliquer comment cela fonctionne et
donc de se faire comprendre par leurs
concitoyens parce que le système est
devenu incompréhensible pour tous entre
la suppression des impôts locaux qui
réduisent l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivité l'intervention croissante
de du législateur dans dans la
définition des bases qui viennent
contredire des stratégies fiscal des
collectivités locales bref tout ça
devient complètement incompréhensible
nous devons redonner des moyens d'agir
aux élus locaux cela aussi c'est lutter
contre leur mal-être évidemment lutter
contre les violences c'est l'objet du
texte cet après-midi protéger davantage
nos élus et je tiens très sincèrement à
saluer l'initiative du Sénat qui est à
l'origine de ce texte saluer que nous
reprenions ce texte ici nous aurons
largement le temps de débattre dans les
détails mais je ne voudrais pas que nous
oublions deux choses qu'il nous restera
à faire évidemment travailler sur le
statut de l'élu local et je me réjouis
que des annonces aent été faites c'est
un P de mer depuis des décennies il faut
que nous nous attaquions à ce sujet-là
et puis enfin appeler à une grande loi
sur les libertés locales permettez-moi
de l'exprimer en ce sens il faut une
grande loi sur les libertés locales pour
qu' enfin nous redonnion localement la
capacité d'agir et que l'État accompagne
les collectivités locales plutôt qu'il
ne
les merci Monsieur Cholen berger la
parole est àadame la viceprésidente jaie
Laforge pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la
Présidente euh madame la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes tous ici présents
nous avons été élus pour porter la voix
de nos concitoyens servir de de courrois
de transmission nous portons cette
vocation républicaine et avons choisi
d'être les représentants du peuple
malheureusement nous nous avons aussi je
pense tous été confrontés à la virulence
aux attaques physiques ou sur les
réseaux sociaux à des menaces ou des
dégradation de notre domicile ou de
notre permanence
parlementaire alors que l'élu local ça a
été dit et le plus apprécié par nos
concitoyens c'est aussi celui qui est le
plus proche des colères et de la
violence c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
dès 2017 avec la loi engagement et
proximité qui a permis la mise en place
d'une protection fonctionnelle s'est
mobilisée cette protection fonctionnelle
pour tous les maires a été mise en place
avec l'obligation pour les communes de
souscrire à une assurance qui puisse
prendre en charge les coûts de
protection fonctionnel la loi de janvier
2023 quant à elle elle permet aux
assemblées d'élus et ça a été aussi
rappelé par Madame la rapporteur et aux
différentes associations de se
constituer parti civil pour soutenir
pleinement au pénal une personne
investie d'un mandat électif public
victime
d'agression comme vous j'ai souhaité
entendre les élus de de ma
circonscription et donc j'ai tenu sur
mon territoire à Saint-Marcelin une
réunion en présence de Dominique fort
ministre à l'époque des collectivités et
lors de cette réunion j'ai pu constater
à quel point finalement la parole des
mares avait besoin de se libérer et
finalement à quel point ce qu'il vivait
au quotidien était gardé et que
finalement porait plainte n'était pas
aussi facile que ça et ça pouvait aussi
montrer qu'il y avait une certaine peur
aussi il faut le dire des des
représailles et donc collectivement ça
vient d'être dit par l'ensemble des des
personnes qui se sont exprimées à cette
tribune je crois que nous avons
conscience de la réalité de ces
violences et de la réalité de ce que
subissent les maires et les élus au
quotidien et donc la réponse ça a été
dit aussi également doit être doit être
ferme on le voit les chiffres le
montrent en 2022 le ministère de
l'Intérieur a recensé
2265 plaintes ou signalement pour des
faits de violence verbale ou physique à
l'encontre des élus c'est une
augmentation de 32 % par rapport à
2021 et donc ça a été dit aussi ce texte
sénatorial il répond à un réel besoin et
nous nous tenons au côté des élus pour
les aider les soutenir les défendre avec
les leviers qui sont à notre disposition
comme cela va être fait par
l'aggravation des peines encu en cas de
violences commises contre les élus nous
améliorons également la protection
fonctionnelle l'accès aux assurances
pour les locaux ou également par
l'allongement des délais de prescription
en cas d'injure ou de diffamation
publique qui seront porté à 1 an
d'autres mesures viennent compléter ce
volet à la fois répressif et
protecteur mais je voudrais vous parler
pour terminer mon intervention de ces
violences qu'on pourrait qualifier de
grise je vous parle de la surveillance
du domicile que peut subir le maire et
sa famille ainsi que ses adjoints et
élus
municipaux je vous parle de la pression
exercée la colère ou les menaces
proférées sur les agents communaux pour
freiner l'action communale voire créer
une pression
psychologique ces actions qui sont
volontairement exercées sur nos élus à
la limite de la légalité c'est pour ça
que je vous parler de zon grise sont
malheureusement vécu de façon
quotidienne c'est aussi ça n'est pas du
harcèlement mais c'est le dénigrement
systématique qui peut être fait sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux alors ce que je
crois c'est que face à la proximité de
cette violence sur nos élus ce texte est
un premier élément un premier élément
essentiel simplement parce que protéger
les élus
ça n'est pas protéger une caste comme
l'a dit la rapporteur c'est finalement
juste protéger notre démocratie dans son
ensemble et donc nous devront continuer
à œuvrer pour soutenir les élus et créer
de nouvelles vocations c'est pourquoi le
groupe démocrate se prononcera en faveur
de ce texte je vous remercie merci
Madame la
vice-présidente la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane de laautrette pour le groupe
socialiste et
apparenté
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
écouté vos propos et je partage avec
vous l'attachement que nous devons avoir
à à nos élus locaux mais reconnaissons
que depuis 2017 le président de la
République a souvent malmené les élus
locaux ces corps intermédiaires
considérés comme autant de frein à sa
stratégie du mouvement et de la Réforme
permanente gérant mal leur collectivité
au point qu'il faille leur imposer 13
milliards d'euros d'économie dès le
début de son quinquena et reprendre en
main leurs ressources fiscales et tout
comme notre collègue Chine berger nous
n'avons pas oublié le hashtag balance
ton m la crise des gilets jaunes et le
covid-19 sont passés par là et le
président semble avoir reçu sa leçon de
choses les élus locaux sont le ciment de
la République et la voix de toutes les
composantes du corps social ils sont
également par les politiques il mettent
en œuvre sa première protection mais qui
protège les élus eux-mêmes tant sur le
plan physique que matériel ou
psychologique depuis 2020 ça a été
rappelé par plusieurs collègues nous
voyons un nombre croissant de démissions
élus locaux écrasé par le manque de
reconnaissance la montée des violences
la complexification de l'action publique
et une forme d'abandon de l'État la loi
3DS devait permettre de gommer certains
des irritants de la loi nôre mais elle a
connu le même sort un texte finalement
éloigné de l'ambition initialement
affichée lors du dernier congrès des
maire Emmanuel Macron a semblé infléchir
sa position annonçant une nouvelle ère
de la décentral isation et une confiance
nouvelle en les élus locaux en attendant
cette éventuelle réforme de la
décentralisation et des moyens des élus
locaux nous avons aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'avancer sur la question du
statut des élus locaux depuis plusieurs
mois nous y travaillons au sein de la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et mon groupe y a
largement contribuer y compris avec une
proposition de loi pour renforcer
l'attractivité des mandats locaux que
nous avions déposé en novembre dernier à
l'occasion du congrès des mairres notre
rapporteur violette spelbout et notre
corapporteur Sébastien Jumel ont aussi
commis un rapport de grande qualité sur
le sujet il y a peu je regrette
cependant vivement qu'ils aient fait le
choix de déposer seul une proposition
issue de ce travail collectif et
transpartisan avec les articles 40 et 45
de la constitution la contribution des
débats parlementaires à ce texte ne
pourra qu'être marginal et c'est très
dommageable indépendemment de la qualité
de son contenu initial nous ne pouvons
pas avancer de manière constructive sur
les sujets liés au collectivité
territoriale sans un large travail
transpartisan aujourd'hui nous abordons
ce chantier sous le seul angle
sécuritaire c'est le choix qui a été
fait par les sénateurs ce texte reprend
de nombreuses mesures proposées par
notre groupe dans le passé et nous ne
pouvons donc qui adhérer nous voterons
donc pour ce texte mon groupe proposera
donc des améliorations à la marge de la
proposition de loi afin qu'elle
répondent au mieux aux attentes des élus
dans la limite de ce que les articles 40
et 45 permettent l'automatisation et le
renforcement de la protection
fonctionnelle accordée aux élus et aux
anciens élus locaux et est une des
principales avancées
annoncées mais nous regrettons que sur
cette mesure comme sur d'autres le Sénat
est distingué les élus avec
délégation avec délégation des élus sans
délégation c'est une erreur car les
agresseurs ne distinguent pas les élus
selon leur arrêtés de délégation ou leur
ordre dans le tableau il y a le plus
souvent le maire et les élus et nous
soutenons les propos tenu par notre
rapporteur sur le sujet monsieur le
ministre vous seul du fait de l'article
40 avez la possibilité de corriger cet
oubli pouvez-vous prendre ici
l'engagement d'étendre cette protection
fonctionnelle à l'ensemble des élus
locaux sans conditions nous proposerons
par ailleurs un meilleur encadrement de
l'engagement de la responsabilité pénale
personnelle des élus locaux en précisant
que celle-ci doit impliquer une faute
caractérisée du maire ou du président et
ne peut découler de la seule
insuffisance de ses services
corrélativement nous proposerons que la
responsabilité de la collectivité en
tant que personne morale puisse être
plus aisément recherché afin que les
droits des victimes soient préservés je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Madame la
vice-présidente Naima mchou pour le
groupe horizon et
[Applaudissements]
apparenté
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues je m'exprime ici à la tribune
au nom d'horizon lieu et place de ma
collègue Marie Agnès poussier vinceb qui
vous prie de l'excuser elle est en
déplacement près de la Marine nationale
je la substitue volontiers et avec en
réalité beaucoup d'intérêt en 2020- 2021
parallèlement au Sénat nous nous
saisissions de ce sujet avec mon
collègue Philippe Gosselin et nous
faisions malheureusement déjà le constat
de l'explosion historique à l'époque des
violence ciblant les élus locaux et les
maires en particulier on a coutume de
dire que par leur ancrage et par leur
proximité les éus locaux sont apportés
d'engueulade pour reprendre l'expression
cher au président l'archer nous
ajoutions avec Philippe Gosselin qu'ils
sont tout autant apporter de cût à tel
point d'ailleurs que nous nous étions
posés la question de la désaffection du
mandat local comme mandat en danger on
le répètera jamais assez ce n'est pas
une figure de style pour le coup sans
prendre un élu saans prendre à la
République elle-même c'est tout aussi
grave il y a des élus locaux ici même à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez été
monsieur le ministre vous-même maire de
la belleeville danger je vous sais très
attaché à ce territoire mais maire dans
le valdoise MES maires c'est affectueux
quand je dis ça les maires du valdoise
chacun que ce soit une petite ville une
grande ville une ville de banlieu ou de
la ruralité touristique ou non chacun
peut témoigner c'est vrai des des
tensions sociales des incivilités des
agressions des difficultés qui se sont
multipliées pour exercer les missions
d'élus et qui peuvent amener au pire et
bien évidemment nous repensons souvent
avec beaucoup de tristesse au décès
brutal de jean-mthieu Michel le maire de
signe le 5 août 2019 qui peuvent amener
aussi ces difficultés à à ce qui est
finalement la décision la plus rude pour
quelqu'un qui s'est engagé dans
l'intérêt général c'est-à-dire la
démission ce constat partagé avec vous
il y a déjà 4 ans et toujours d'une
triste actualité et la question demeure
qui voudra encore à ce rythme s'engager
dans une municipalité au détriment de sa
sécurité et de sa famille évidemment
personne ne peut accepter un tel échec
et tout ce qui peut utilement protéger
nos territoire et leurs élus et bienvenu
c'est l'intérêt de ce texte qui
accompagne le plan national annoncé par
le gouvernement de prévention et de
lutte contre les violences aux élus et
qui complète d'autres mesures qui sont
déjà en vigueur comme le centre
d'analyse et de lutte des atteintes aux
élus de 2023 comme le renforcement des
moyens de la justice évidemment comme la
mobilisation accru des forces de
sécurité d'ailleurs à ce titre nous
proposions avec mon collègue
Gosselin d'affermir les pouvoirs de
police des maires des policiers
municipaux et je continue d'ailleurs te
plaider en ce sens et puis nous aurons
l'occasion je l'espère de débattre du
statut de l'élu local à travers les
recommandations et le rapport
l'excellent rapport de nos collègues
violette spilbut et Sébastien Jumel mon
groupe soutiendra cette proposition de
loi que ce soit la mesure de prise en
charge médicale et psychologique assurée
par la collectivité l'automaticité de la
protection fonctionnelle l'accès aux
assurances garanties pour les locaux
politiques les permanences
parlementaires nous sommes quelques-uns
y avoir été confrontés nous serons
favorables bien sûr au renforcement des
sanctions qui sont encouru en cas de
violence commise contre les élus comme
je suis tenace je reviendrai moi-même
avec un nouveau texte sur l'instauration
de peine planché en cas de récidive
d'agression commise contre les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique vous
avez l'exclusivité de l'annonce je note
avec satisfaction nous irons également
vers une meilleure information des
maires des maires par les parquets quand
au suite donné à leur plainte et au
signalement alors ça c'est une des
mesures que nous portions avec notre
collègue dans ce donc ce rapport
formation que j'ai appelé
goslutchou mesure que j'avais porté
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi de lutte contre la
récidive mais qui n'avait pas obtenu
d'accueil favorable à l'époque du
gouvernement mais heureusement les temps
changent et les ministres changent je
salue également le renforcement de la
présence des préfets et des procureurs
au sein des conseils locaux de sécurité
et de prévention de la délinquence autre
mesures que nous
recommandions pour tous ceux qui
s'engagent pour nos territoires et bien
le groupe horizon veut redire son entier
soutien sa détermination les protégé
rappelle également qu'il faut poursuivre
le travail et certainement aller plus
loin nous voterons ce texte qui est une
nouvelle occasion à saisir pour
revaloriser le beau le beau mandat le
précieux mandat d'élus local c'est une
question de démocratie
merci je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Jean-Claude R pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste
merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la rapporteur chers collègues chaque
fois qu'une élu chaque fois qu'un élu
est agressé c'est une part de notre
démocratie qui s'affae parce que la
démocratie doit justement rester une
forme de gouvernance sans violence
partout et tout le temps 32 %
d'augmentation des atteintes aux élus en
2022 dans mon département de la loi
Atlantique j'ai connu le domicile brûlé
de Yannick morz ancien maire de
saint-brévin- lespins les insultes
publiques et menaces de mort contre agès
Bourget mire de reusé la tentative
d'attaque au couteau contre la mre de
bounet Sandra impériale et plus
récemment les menaces de mort contre
Marie Alexis Lefeuvre maire de la
commune de safré où j'habite chaque
nouvelle violence reste un choc ce
constate d'une hausse des violences
envers les élus doit toutes tous nous
alerter nous faire réagir nous en tant
que parlementaire bien sûr mais nous en
tant que citoyenes et citoyens surtout
nous l'exprimons clairement les
violences à lagard des élus sous quelque
forme que ce soit ne sont pas tolérabl
dans notre société et doivent être
condamnés il ne s'agit pas de faire des
élus des citoyens à part mais d'assurer
leur protection dans l'exercice de leur
fonctions bien sûr il est ell demeurent
responsable de leurs actes à l'image de
ce que nous voulons pour les ministres
avec la suppression de la Cour de
Justice de la
République mais nous mais nous devons
éradiquer les violences à l'égard des
élus locaux et durcir les sanctions en
sachant que le droit pénal ne peut pas
tout il vient punir mais non prévenir
aggraver les peines encourues ne doit
pas masquer les raisons
multifactorielles de ces agressions
c'est aussi sur ces causes qu'il faudra
agir pour pour parvenir à endiguer le
mal le premier chantier vital est celui
du rapprochement des élus et des
citoyens celui du ravivement de la
confiance dans un système démocratique
de gouvernement celui de l'accès de
chacune et chacun aux institutions sans
discrimination de fait n'ayons pas peur
de le dire notre fonctionnement
démocratique n'est pas parfait il écarte
et méprise trop souvent la voix de
celles et ceux qui n'occupent pas les
fauteuils du pouvoir le délitement de la
conviction dans des institutions
démocratique peut-être une cause le
délaissement par l'état de ces missions
et l'abandon de personnes à leur
détresse en sont une autre les maires
sont le punching ball verbal et physique
des premières victimes des politiques
néolibéral qui appauvrissent les
personnes détruisent nos services
médicaux et
médicausociaux aggrave les troubles de
santé
mentale tant que le gouvernement
perdurera à détricoter les services
publics d'un côté les violences dans
notre société ne feront invariablement
que s'accroître de
l'autre les violence émane aussi d'une
volonté politique d'une stratégie
mortifère parce que la violence à
saint-brévin- lespins c'était l'extrême
droite ceux qui disaient on est chez
nous mais qui étaent venu d'ailleurs en
car et qui était d'ailleurs beaucoup
moins nombreux que les partisans du CADA
pour nourrir la polémique et pour
pourrir la vie d'une commune où
l'accueil des migrants n'avait jamais
jamais posé de problème depuis 2016
l'extrême droite qui se revigore et se
décomplexe par la diffusion de ces
thèmes et de ces termes par des médias
comme par les élus de la
République car il ne faut pas nous
voiler la face et faire comme si les
violences auxquelles s'exposent les élus
ne s'expliquaient pas aussi par la
manipulation la récupération par une
idéologie de la haine souvent relayée
par les réseaux
sociaux mais pour revenir à notre
objectif du moment parce qu'il
contribuera en partie à améliorer
l'accompagnement des élus victimes et la
réponse aux violences subies parce qu'il
est nécessaire bien que pas suffisant ce
texte sera voté par le groupe écologiste
nupes sous réserve de nos débats je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe
Gauche démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine s'il vous plaîtes chers
collèguessieur a la parole merci
merci présidente monsieur le ministre
chers collègues rapporteur chers
collègues devenir maèire c'est endosser
le plus beau des mandats devenir mère
c'est s'engager dans une forme de
sacerdoce
laïque devenir maère c'est accepter de
prendre en charge son territoire de
réveiller les esprits dans les villages
victimes de le du trou métropolisation
et du déménagement du territoire devenir
maire c'est s'occuper des repas à la
cantine organiser les célébrations du 14
juillet écouter ceux qui vont mal dans
sa commune réconcilier les voisins
lorsqu'ils ne s'entendent plus devenir
mère c'est croire comme Bernanos que les
petites choses n'ont l'air de rien mais
qu'elle donne la paix devenir mère c'est
prendre soin de ce qui semble invisible
de ce qui semble évident et qui pourtant
s'ffrite le lien social dans une époque
où il il est parfois si facile de croire
que l'avenir est au présent à l'immédiat
au distantiel aux relations numériques à
la société liquide être maire c'est
assumer avoir les deux pieds dans la
terre et de prendre soin concrètement du
lien social qui ne pourra pas être
remplacé par un
smartphone lorsque nous avons le
sentiment et je crois que ce sentiment
est partagé que la démocratie
s'abîme que le fossé se creuse entre nos
concitoyens et ceux qui sont chargé
d'apporter la réponse publique maire
élus locaux eux gardent la maison France
en respectant le seul devoir qui incombe
à ceux qui s'engagent continuer à faire
communauté porter haut et fier la devise
romaine de ce qui de ce que veut dire la
commune c'est-à-dire vivre
ensemble loin de se laisser souffler des
slogans publicitaires par les cabinets
de
conseil si l'on veut véritablement
réarmer la politique et la République il
faut soutenir nos communes le maire à
les pieds sur terre il est àorté
d'angueulade ça a été dit par plusieurs
sans garde rapproché sans filtre sans
caméra il conserve lui la confiance des
Français parce qu'il vit et il est lié
avec eux car le maire c'est tout à la
fois le premier visage de ce qu'on
appelle l'état la France la République
et celui qui fait vivre ses grands grand
mot au quotidien parfois d'illeurs en
ayant le sentiment qui le fait contre V
et Maré quand l'État n'est pas au
rendez-vous quand l'État détricote les
services publics de proximité ou quand
l'État rogne sur les moyens des communes
les maires urgentistes de la République
tiennent debout la baraque France et
d'ailleurs nous l'avons vu au moment du
covid face à la crise de l'inflation au
moment de la crise des gilets jaunes où
y compris le président de la République
avait semblé redécouvrir le rôle des
maires il est précieux quand ça se
fragilise il est précieux contou fouc le
maire il Rafistol il rustine lorsque
l'état quelquefois sert fort le bras
droit et relâche malement son bras
gauche lorsque les dotations de
fonctionnement les recettes fiscales les
pouvoirs d'agir des élus locaux se
morcell au rythme des réformes
territoriales j'espère que la mission v
nous permettra d'avoir une lecture
critique remise en cause de la loi nôre
qui n'est pas la nôtre et qui a fait mal
au territoire de proximité alors lorsque
la charge déjà trop lourde devient
violente les maires se questionnent ils
alertent souvent et parfois ils s'en
vont en silence discrètement et nous en
avons avec Violette spbout
auditionné de nombreux et tous les
témoignages additionnés nous ont
conforté dans l'idée qu'il fallait être
au rendez-vous et qu'il fallait une loi
qui symboliquement je le dis compris à
mes collègues insoumis avec beaucoup de
fraternité qui avec symboliquement
devait marquer le fait que on ne touche
pas un maire lorsqu'il est au service de
l'intérêt général et que violenter un
maire s'en prendre à son entourage s'en
prendre à son domicile impliquer une
réponse pénale à la hauteur du symbole
porté contre la République alors ça a
été dit par plusieurs est-ce que cette
réponse pénale suffit évidemment que non
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
avec ma collègue rapporteur on va vous
proposer de prolonger cela pour élaborer
un véritable statut de l'élu local qui
prenneent en compte la nécessité de
prendre soin de ceux qui prennent soin
de la République pour renforcer les
pouvoirs d'agir des élus parce que j'ai
nourri la conviction en étant mère
moi-même que on ne protège efficacement
on ne protège dans la durée que les gens
qui sont concrètement utiles à nos
concitoyens de ce point de vue là la
manière de donner plus de moyens au ma
dans les sujets qui touchent au
quotidien devront être au service des
habitants voilà l'état d'esprit qui
anime le groupe communiste en
appréhendant cette loi avec la volonté
de la voter mais avec la volonté de la
prolonger par une loi future je vous
remcie merci la parole est maintenant à
Madame Emmanuelle
[Applaudissements]
mard merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le
dire en commission ma première réaction
face à cette proposition de loi a été
assez mitigé en effet je n'aime pas trop
ce qui peut donner l'impression que nous
nous accordons une sorte de privil
un de plus dirait probablement beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui seraiit refusé
aux autres il faut néanmoins reconnaître
que cette proposition de loi répond à
une préoccupation croissante des élus
locaux quant à leur sécurité quelques
chiffres ont été rappelés ici assez
significatif 32 % d'agression en plus
essentiellement à l'encontre des maires
entre 2021 et 2022 selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur il s'agit principalement
d'outrage pour 50 % de de menace pour 40
% et de violence volontaire pour 10 %.
selon d'autres chiffres intéressants
tiré d'un sondage auoxa de novembre
dernier pour Le Figaro 64 % des Français
estiment que la sécurité des mares est
mal assurée et 61 % pensent qu'il
pourrai personnellement renoncer à se
présenter à une élection municipale par
crainte pour eux-mêmes ou pour leur
famille ces chiffres sont éloquent
l'objectif de ce texte est donc de
proposer des solutions qui rassureront
nos élus les mesures envisagées vont de
l'aggravation des sanctions en cas de
violence contre les élus à
l'amélioration de la prise en charge des
élus victimes en passant par une
meilleure implication des institutions
dans la protection des élus ces mesures
sont ciblées et spécifiques il est
pourtant nécessaire d'examiner plus
largement leurs implications afin
d'assurer un équilibre entre sécurité et
liberté civile d'autant que la
Commission a voté certaines dispositions
qui me semblent problématiques j'y
reviendrai
je l'ai déjà évoqué lors de l'examen de
ce texte en commission la proposition de
loi qui se concentre sur la réponse
répressive et la protection après les
agressions pourrait être enrichie par
des mesures préventives plus globales je
pense notamment à la mise en place de
système de signalement et de réponses
rapid pour les menaces ou incidents qui
permettrai une intervention rapide et
efficace en cas de problème comme cela
se fait déjà dans certaines communes par
exemple pour les commerces ou les écoles
en en l'impact de la loi sur les
libertés civiles et notamment la liberté
d'expression pose question il me semble
notamment qu'un risque existe que les
mesures proposées laissent place à une
interprétation abusive la liberté
d'expression et le droit de la presse
consacré par la loi de 1881 sont des
questions compliquées sensibles
juridiquement et la proposition de loi y
touche en évoquant notamment dans son
article 2 bis les problèmes liés à la
diffamation aux injures et aux outrages
pour être tout à fait clair il me semble
que nous ne devrions toucher à cette loi
de 1881 sur la liberté de la presse
qu'avec beaucoup de précautions s'il est
vrai que les possibilités d'action
judiciaair contre les délits de presse
sont enserré dans des délis courts et
que les évolutions technologiques
réseaux sociaux internet intelligence
artificielle favorisent la persistance
de la diffusion des contenus injurieux
et diffamatoires dans l'espace public et
leur accessibilité dans le temps
allonger le délai de prescription
relatif à un élément déterminé de la loi
comme le fait cet article de BIS risque
d'entraîner des difficultés au regard
des autres délaiis de prescription qui
continuent à s'appliquer en matière de
presse ma principale crainte est de
déséquilibrer la loi de
1881 et ce faisant d'aller à l'encontre
de l'objectif politique visée en l'état
je voterai donc contre cet article de
bis un mot encore sur les dispositions
entourant le conseil local de sécurité
et de prévention de la délinquence déjà
qu'il n'est pas loin de ressembler à une
usine à gaz imaginez y incorporer une
participation citoyenne tirée au sort
comme cela a été ajouté en commission à
l'article 14 relève selon moi de la
démagogie pure et
simple un mot enfin sur les agressions
elle-même si cette proposition de loi
tente d'apporter quelques solutions le
point de départ de la protection apporté
aux élus devrait me semble-t-il être à
minima la condamnation unanime de ces
violences y compris lorsque la victime
ne relève pas du même camp politique
j'ai en tête l'agression dont avait été
victime le maire de Bézier toujours en
attente du moindre mot de soutien lors
d'un déplacement à saint-entrée de
kubzac en mai 2018 sous les drapeaux de
la gauche et de l'extrême gauche alors
vous l'avez compris je ne m'opposerai ce
texte mais je pense qu'il mériterait à
minima un peu moins d'hypocrisie je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la discussion générale est
close